gyneco moi je suis très nul n'est réglé
en sténo fois j'écris en sténo des
hiéroglyphes je fais pas ou par exemple
est ce que vous étiez en france est un
mauvais but au bacon français pour ceux
qui ont passé le bac 8 9 ou bien sûr ce
sera le certificat d'état qu'on ne fera
plus au nul
vous allez connaître un autographe une
cata et au niveau des eaux un niveau là
le raf une cascade licata et le français
mahut fait je crois donc vous êtes un
mauvais l'écrit move alors alloué
mauvais les clubs alors oui non c'est
ton français cet enfant disant vous êtes
vous avez une grande culture benjamin
oui mais oui mais le français sur nuke
benhaim un café on gagne époques calmes
et hip hop à table vous allez créer 17 à
l'oral quoi nous a dit voilà la dure
brouillé l'organiser à l'examinateur
alors alouettes 7 où elle est belle je
me souviens plus des mains et celles des
bonnes mais je suis imbattable en
orthographe s'arrête pas près par oui
vraiment mais bon j'ai pas testé sa non
non vous moi j'ai arrêté l'école à 15
ans donc je suis une balle en
orthographe
mais depuis que je suis à quand des gens
des fois des gens importants grâce à
vous des fois faut que j'envoie des
mails faut que je réponde tellement peur
que même le correcteur il me donne pas
le mot en fête se tenait sur google pour
aller voir commence à s'écrire et après
envoyé mon texto je m'attends pas
possible chez moi c'est la même école
d'accord c'est bien merci en tout cas là
elle veut pas prendre de risque oui j'ai
merdé c'est par écrit 17 à l'oral à l'as
khroub les hôpitaux
c'est vrai 17 à l'équipe nationale se
passe de mythos u17 obama n 18 a
influencé était ici et 18 en philo et 18
en philo les frères falic vont hanter à
faire du 17 17
parce que j'ai eus j'avais 3 ans match
j'avais arrêté les maths en fait donc
cédé sur m6
on croit vous avez ou 15 à l'écrit 16 à
l'oral c'est en philo c'est ton la fin
c'est en latin fera pas l'affairé des
dictats nuss alors j'ai passé un bac b
sciences économiques sociales à l'époque
on disait b14 allait créer 12 à l'oral
non oui mais il est bon simon tient
maintenant j'étais meilleur en philo
j'ai eu 16 en philo ce mois tu crois que
tu enterres tout à colon et en maths 8
huawei belle affaire christine kelly
franchement je me rappelle pas du tout
parce que je dit est le français je me
rappelle pas de mine note d'accor est
basse et ni le français ni histoire
gmail et matt que les maths la physique
et en maths c'est pas une bonne note
mais honnêtement je redescends tes deux
minutes 8
doc gynéco moi je suis très nul nul j'ai
créé en sténo fois j'écris en sténo des
hiéroglyphes je fais pas l'envoyer
essayez de savoir ce qu'il a voulu dire
il a dit j'ai des héros glyphes sténo
oui oui j'ai une écriture pas possible
impossible vraiment c'est vous avez
passé le bac même pas non mais pas
passer le bac
non non j'ai arrêté l'école moi aussi
mais plus tard plus tard quand même peu
tard que le lac avant mais vous savez
non m'arrêter maintenant
non mais vous êtes et c'est quoi un
troisième est votre cursus relief
particulier j'ai beaucoup traîné dehors
d'accord mais au niveau de l'est des
études et brûlées selon quelle classe
aux pattes je sais il avait été au
collège
ah oui oui au collège louis le collègue
c'est que jusqu'à troisième alors ouais
c'est ça et après la seconde ça vous dit
quelque chose non alors j'ai embrayé
j'ai passé la première j'ai pas fait
tout ça d'études c'est beaucoup c'est
avec ces va pas revenir enfin c'est bien
je vais vous dire la vérité il écrivait
ses vieux et je le dis et c c'est pas
une vanne
j'ai eu 12 à l'écrit c'est bien et j'ai
eu très à l'oral non on va vérifier
non je vous le dis non c'est bien vous
êtes tombé sur vous souvenez du texte
que vous avez reçu les lettres persanes
montesquieu trop j'embrasse d'ailleurs
mangé avec lui hier soir
il ya un bon coup de fourchette
[Musique]